إنه مرض طفيلي بالكاد
يوجد بعد الآن، ويرجع الفضل في ذلك جزئيًا إلى العمل الذي
قام به هذا الرئيس السابق الذي كنا
نقوده، وفي المدرسة الابتدائية
كان لدى الأطفال لافتة كبيرة تقول احذروا من
الإصابة بالدودة، هنا يأتي جيمي كارتر،
والتي كانت تقريبًا جيدة مثل جائزة نوبل.
بالنسبة لي في الثمانينات قرر كارتر أن
يقود الجهود لتخليص العالم من أمراض
غينيا التي
أصابها حوالي ثلاثة ملايين ونصف مليون
شخص اعتبارا من عام 2022 هناك 13 حالة
حسب المجاميع الأولية من
مركز كارتر أمراض الدودة الغينية
التي يسببها طفيلي يصيب
الإنسان  والحيوانات عندما تشرب
مياهًا غير مفلترة ملوثة
بأساطيل مياه مجهرية، لا تظهر على الأشخاص المصابين أي
أعراض لمدة عام تقريبًا ثم
يبدأون في الشعور بالمرض مع حمى طفيفة
وطفح جلدي وحكة وغثيان وقيء وإسهال
ودوار، ثم تظهر نفطة مؤلمة
وتخترق الدودة
الجلد  يأتي مع مجموعة من
المضاعفات الصحية الأخرى في حين أن
معدل الوفيات منخفض، والإعاقة شائعة،
وحقيقة أننا نعرف مكان
وجود المرض الآن نعرف ما هي الأدوية أو
العلاج الذي يمكن أن يكون فعالاً ويمكننا
في الواقع إثبات
أه كم عدد الأشخاص الذين ما زالوا مصابين
هذه المشكلة ويمكننا إثبات ما الذي
يسبب النجاح وأعتقد أن هذا الدليل
يزيد من احتمالية
استمرار الجهود بعد
رئيس آخر للدقيقة الصحية أنا
آندي غايثر